翻訳: Hiroyuki Sugiura
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
僕がですね 小学校５年生のころ
父親が 働き過ぎで 脳出血になりまして
半身不随で 寝たきりになりました
その時にですね
大きくなったら お医者さんになろう
って思いまして
一生懸命勉強しました
そして 自治医科大学という大学に
入学することができました
その大学は
学費を一銭も払わなくていいんですね
生活費もいただける
しかし卒業してから 地元に戻り
私の場合は 静岡県ですけれども
地域医療
そして僻地医療
皆さん 僻地ってわかりますか？
山の中
お医者さんが あまりいないところですよね
そこで ９年間 働かなければいけません
なぜ自治医大を選んだかというと
親に迷惑をかけたくなかった
そんな単純な理由からです
そして医学部を卒業し
私は浜松市北部にあります
山の中の小さな町
佐久間町と言うところの
小さな病院 佐久間病院に
赴任させていただきました
学費と引き換えの義務とはいえですね
30歳そこそこの
最も成長しなければいけない
もっとも最先端の医学を
学ばなければいけない医者として
そんな30歳の時に
山の中の小さな病院に行くっていうのは
正直なところ
本意ではありませんでした
そして赴任当初
４年間が ものすごく長く感じました
40％
ちょっとこの数字を考えてください
これは何の数字か分かりますか？
40％
実は私が赴任した佐久間町
当時 今から20年前ですけれども
高齢化率が40％でした
高齢化率とは 全人口に占める
65歳以上の割合を言います
高齢化率40％の佐久間町
お年寄りがいっぱいいます
だって人口の半分弱が
65歳以上のお年寄りなんですから
しかし この40％ 非常に重要です
実は 2050年の
日本全国 平均の高齢化率が
40％になります
現在は27％です
27％でも日本は
世界ダントツ高齢化率が高い国です
そして約30年後 40％になります
2050年 40％
当時『バック・トゥ・ザ・フューチャー』
という
映画が流行っておりましたけれども
私はその時 思いました
あっ ひょっとしたら自分は
タイムマシンに乗って
2050年の日本に来て 未来に来て
医療をしてるんじゃないかと
そう考えるとですね
非常にやりがいを持って
医療をすることが できました
そして
当初４年間は長いなと
思っていたんですけれども
「住めば都」
昔の人は良く言ったものですね
住んでいるうちにですね
だんだん 居心地が
良くなってきたんですね
なぜですか？
その理由ですけど
この笑顔 見てください
すごい美しいでしょ
これは住民の皆さんです
佐久間町の
住民の方々にですね
本当によくしてもらいました
僕は「家庭医」
「ファミリードクター」と言いまして
家族全員を診る家庭医でしたので
まさに家族ぐるみで
住民の方々と
お付き合いさせていただきました
そして これは家庭医の
宿命でもありますけれども
非常に沢山の方々の
死を 看取らせていただきました
おそらく ４年間で100人を
優に超えていたと思います
当時30歳の私
もちろん医者としての
仕事なんですけれども
毎日 毎日
お年寄りを看取るということは
非常に悲しいものがありました
しかしそんな中
もうすでにあの世に行って ―
天国に行ってしまった
患者様たちが 様々なことを
私に教えていただきました
その中の２つを取り上げます
「人生は一度しかない」
そして
「人生は長いようで短い」
この２つの言葉は その後の私の人生に
非常に大きな意味を成すのでした
そして ４年間の義務が終わりに近づいたころ
もう正直な話 私はこの町で
一生住んでもいいという風に
気持ちが変わっておりました
しかし ちょうどその頃
80歳を超える とあるおじいさんを
看取ることになりました
そして そのおじいさんが亡くなる前に
私に こんなことを言いました
「先生」
「先生は まだ若い」
「我々のこんな田舎の町の中で
一生懸命 医者として働いてくれて
ありがとう
でも 先生何かやりたいことが
あるんじゃないか？」
80歳を超える人生を振り返ってみて
何かやりたいことがあって
チャレンジしなかった時は
ものすごい後悔するみたいです
まだ僕は80歳になったことがないから
わからないですけども
そのおじいさんが言ったのは
「何かやりたいことがあって
チャレンジして
ダメだった 失敗したことは
意外と後悔しない」
「もし先生が
何かやりたいことがあるんだったら
やってみたらどうかね」
この言葉はですね
私の体に 電撃的な刺激を与えました
何か体の中で 眠っていたものが
起こされた気がします
熱いマグマのようなものが
メラメラと体内から
上がってくるような感じがしました
実は私 一生で一度でいいので
海外に住んでみたい
世界の舞台で戦ってみたい
そんな気持ちがありました
しかし 残念ながらコネも無い
実力もない
ましてや金もない
正直言って
無茶な夢だと思って諦めておりました
そんな時に
私が患者さんを送っていた
都市部の心臓の専門病院に
見学に行くチャンスを与えられました
そして そこの院長先生から
こんな質問を受けました
「君は僻地医療が終わったら
何をするのかね？」
僕は非常にかしこまって
教科書どおりの返事をしました
「はい 静岡県の地域医療に
一生を尽くします」
そうすると そこの院長先生が
ものすごくおっかない顔で
「本当にやりたいことがあるんだったら
言ってみろ」と
その時に 初めて僕は本音を言いました
「一生一度でいいので 海外に留学してみたい
でも 僕にとってはそれは 夢
絶対かなわない夢だから
無理だと思います」
すると その院長先生が
ニヤッと笑って
「留学したいんだったら
紹介してやってもいいぞ」
そういう風に言われたんですね
非常に 非常に不思議なくらい
とんとん拍子に留学が決まりました
実は私 神様とか全く信じない
人間なんですけれど
その時だけは
ひょっとしたら
私が看取った
あのアドバイスをくださった
おじいさんが天国から
私をひょっとしたら
導いてくれたんじゃないかな
それぐらい不思議な感覚がしました
そして留学先は
アメリカ合衆国 カリフォルニア州
シリコンバレーのスタンフォード大学です
ただし
残念ながら
そんなに甘い話ではありません
３年間 私は給料なしの
無給で働かなきゃいけない
そういう条件で
３年間の留学が許されていました
シリコンバレーは
世界で最も物価の高い地域です
４人の子どもと
１人の妻
妻が２人いたら困りますけれども
（笑）
その家族がですね
世界で最も物価の高いシリコンバレー
そして私は貯金を食いつぶして
そこに行く覚悟だったんですけれども
どうあがいても
１年サバイバルするのが やっとでした
その時に私を
スタンフォードに紹介してくれた
その院長先生が
私たちを哀れに思ったのか
生活費を工面してくださると
言ってくださいました
しかし
その見返りとして
２つの義務を果たせと
悪人顔で迫ってきました
１つ目の義務
「世界中に友達を作りなさい」
大体人間 ２つ何か条件出してくると
１つ目は良いことを言うんですよね
（笑）
それで 安心させるんですよ
きっと２つ目が
凄いどぎついことを言ってですね
一生俺の病院で
安月給で働けとかですね
まあそんな感じ
それでも私はアメリカに行きたかったです
スタンフォードに行きたかった
いやもう全然OKですと
じゃあ２つ目は何ですかと
ーちなみにー みたいな話をして
ビクビクしながら
一応聞いたんですけど
２つ目
「スタンフォードに行って
日本の未来を一生懸命考えてくれ
以上」
たったそれだけでしたね
そして 2001年４月
家族で
アメリカはカリフォルニア州
シリコンバレーにあります
スタンフォード大学に留学しました
しかし
人生 そんなに甘くありません
私が 所属したラボはですね
シリコンバレーのベンチャーと一緒に
新しい医療機器を開発する
そのような研究室だったわけですね
しかし 当然のことながら
研究もしたことがない
英語もロクに喋れない
そして 静岡県の山の中の小さな病院から
世界最高峰のスタンフォード大学に
行ったわけですから
当然のことながら
全く相手にされませんでした
しかし
生活費と引き換えの１つ目のミッション
「世界中に友達を作る」
これだけは 一生懸命しました
ただ単に 世界中に友達を作るために
困っている人がいたら いろいろ助けました
人が嫌がる仕事も
ニコニコ喜んでしました
そして 大学学内だけではなくて
大学の外にも友達を
沢山作る努力をしました
３年間やりました
そして ３年の留学が終わりに近づいた頃
スタンフォード大学から
信じられないオファーをいただきました
ポストを用意する
給料も払う
頼むからスタンフォードに残ってくれ
実はですね
いろんな人を助けている時にですね
いろんなプロジェクトに参加してたんですね
いろんなベンチャーの
お手伝いをしていた時に
いろんな会社のベンチャーとですね
一緒に仕事をすることになりました
そうこうしているうちに 学内
そしてシリコンバレーに
良い噂が流れてたんですね
「あいつと一緒に仕事すると成功するぞ」と
気が付いたらですね
業績がものすごくあったんですね
僕は あまり業績とか
全然考えない人間だったんですけれども
17年経った今でも
未だにスタンフォードで
サバイバルできています
しかし これは
自分の実力なんかではありません
あくまでも 他人が
私を助けてくれたからです
このとき思いました
やっぱり人は人によって
支えられてるんだな
そういう風に思いました
そして ２つ目のミッション
２つ目のミッションは
「日本の未来を考えてくれ」
この命題は 私には非常に重すぎて
考えられる余地がありませんでした
しかし
それを考えざるを得ない事件が起こりました
2011年3月11日東北大震災
日本の大事件です
このとき私は ２つ目のミッション
これを遂行する時期が来たと思いました
医療ボランティアとして
福島に
医療ボランティア
医師として参加する
それに申し込みました
今までいろんな人に助けられた
今度は 私が
日本の皆さまを助ける時が来たと
しかし 福島に行く前日
オバマ大統領が
福島原発から半径80キロ圏外に
アメリカ関係者は退避するように
という命令が下りました
もちろんスタンフォード大学にも
そのような命令が来ています
私は日本人ですが
アメリカの大学の職員です
残念ながら
福島に行くことは できませんでした
日本のために何かできる
できると思ったのにできない
正直自分は自己嫌悪と
自信喪失に陥りました
自分は本当に
社会に必要とされている人間なのかと
日本がピンチの時に何もできない
正直 恥ずかしい話ですけれども
昼間からお酒を飲んで紛らしたりとか
半分 鬱病直前ぐらいまで
追い込められていました
しかしその時に
佐久間のお年寄りの言葉が
私の所によみがえってきました
「人生は一度しかない」
「人生は長いようで短い」
「挑戦して失敗したことを後悔しない」
なんだか天国からですね
佐久間の看取った患者さんたちが
私に何かを問いかけてきたんだと思います
そして私は立ち上がりました
震災直後 安倍政権が
日本経済復興のために
「３本の矢」政策を遂行しました
その３本目の矢
それが
医療産業によって
経済発展を再興すると
特に日本はモノづくりが得意です
そのモノづくりを生かして
医療機器を 日本で開発し
そして それによって産業を発展させていく
そのような国家戦略が練られました
僕はもうこの瞬間
これしかないと思いました
自分ができること
自分がしなければならないこと
自分にしかできないこと
これによって
日本に貢献しようと思いました
キーワードは
「医療」
そして 「医療機器」「高齢化社会」です
この３つのキーワードを元に
日本とアメリカ
太平洋を挟んだ架け橋を作る
つまり簡単に言うと
日本とアメリカが協力して
医療イノベーションを起こす
これが 私がしなければならないことだ
そのように思いました
そして実行に移します
2013年
私は 60億の
資産を運用する
ベンチャーキャピタルを設立しました
ベンチャーキャピタルを設立して
いろんなベンチャーを
日本から作っていこう
そのように思ってます
今もやってます
２つ目
日本に起業家育成講座を設立する
特に医療に限った
起業家育成講座
これは国家プロジェクトの
ひとつですけれども
2015年から初めております
そして アメリカと日本の
医療のプロフェッショナルをつなぐNPO
こちらも設立してます
そして先月
高齢化社会に対して
シリコンバレーの技術と
日本のニーズ
この２つを組み合わせ
現在の日本の高齢化社会の課題を
みんなで考えて 解決していく
シンクタンクを設立しました
日本は 現在 高齢化率
ダントツ世界トップです
お年寄りが 沢山いる国です
しかし そのお年寄りの沢山いる国 日本で
その高齢化社会に対する
解決するアイディアを出せば
それが将来 日本だけではなくて
世界の高齢化社会に
貢献することができるように
なるかもしれません
佐久間町で
2050年の医療を経験しました
それを今
世界の病める患者さんに適応しております
17年前までは日本で 臨床医として
目の前の病める患者さんを
救っておりました
そして
現在
私は 日米の架け橋を作って
病める患者さんを救おうとしています
いずれにしても小学校の時の
志高く患者さんを救いたいという
気持ちは全く変わっておりません
昨年１年間で 私は33回
日米を往復しました
人は人によって
人生の新たな選択肢をいただく
ということを学びました
皆さまに私が
佐久間の皆さまから
いただいた言葉を
捧げたいと思います
「人生は一度しかない」
「人生は長いようで短い」
「挑戦して失敗したことは後悔しない」
そして 院長先生からいただいた
２つのミッション
「世界中に友達を作りなさい」
「日本の未来を考えてくれ」
そして それよりも
もっともっと大事なことがあります
それは
「行動に移す！」ことです
自分の夢 日本の夢
世界の夢のために
「行動に移す！」
しかし なかなか皆さん
世界は突然変えられないと思います
しかし
皆さま自身は変えられると思います
今日ここに集まった300人の方々
一人一人が
自分を変えて行動に移してみてください
日本が変わるかもしれない
そしてそれが 世界を良い方向に
導くのかもしれません
皆さん どんな些細なことでも
どんな小さなことでも構いません
自分のために行動してみてください
そして
それが世界を変えると 私は信じております
（拍手）